I've had Gwen as my best friend and I
can see the way she helps you to believe
in yourself
grab the tissues because Blake Shelton
and Gwen Stefani are handing out feels
and it's gonna get emotional so I feel
really just so grateful on Monday's
episode of The Voice
Gwen's two remaining team members faced
off to determine who would make it
through to the live shows
[Music]
that was destiny rain bringing the house
down with her rendition of Demi Lovato's
tell me you love me but it was rose
short who really stole the show with her
version of Jessie J's big white room
[Music]
damn yeah that was so freakin good it
had Kelly Clarkson and John Legend on
their feet like from the get-go
[Music]
needless to say Gwen had a tough
decision to make and turn to her fellow
coaches for help that's when her beau
chimed in rose I couldn't be happier for
you that you have Gwen as your coach
because I've had when as my best friend
and I can see the effect that it has on
somebody the way she helps you to
believe in yourself
I'm not crying you're crying no really
though everybody was crying this man
actually has a heart in the end
Gwen sent Rose through to the live shows
with an emotional endorsement Rose is a
teacher turn that turned into a major
threat and everybody is definitely
scaring Rose in October Blake opened up
to et about how he and his ladylove
handle going head-to-head on the
competition show at the end of the day I
wouldn't it's no different than if win
and I were playing you know cards or you
know any kind of game you know she wants
to win and I want to win that's what
they pay us to do on this show is to try
to win the show and even with all that
friendly competition there love just
keeps getting stronger
it's incredible to have a best friend
like that guy he's an amazing person
Glen and Blake forever I'm saying it now
they really are the cutest couple in
Hollywood and you can count on et to
loop you in on all of their sweet
moments so make sure to keep it locked
or right here until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens bye for now
[Music]